hey what's up guys mkbhd here so in
honor of recent events that have the
word hd in them we're going to be taking
a look at the asus zenbook prime with
the hd display as you don't already know
the motorola razer hd was announced two
days ago
and the amazon kindle fire hd was
announced yesterday so today we're gonna
be taking a look at the ultrabook with
the hd screen the 1080p 13 inch matte
laptop let's go ahead and take a look so
think of this ux 32 as an upgraded
version of the ux31 the x31 of last year
if you haven't already watched it i
review the ux31 it's the first link in
the description below the like button on
this video and it's one of my favorite
ultrabooks out there so this ux 32 is an
upgrade so it has some neat new features
first off inside is an upgraded 1.9
gigahertz intel core i7 iv bridge
processor and dedicated graphics card an
nvidia gt620m and that graphics card has
one gig of video memory and there's
eight gigs of upgradable ram on board
and an ssd for the operating system and
a 500 gig upgradable seven millimeter
hard drive for storage this thing has
beastly laptop specs with most
ultrabooks the ram and the storage are
soldered to the motherboard so they're
not upgradable but they are here and
this is all wrapped in a nice thin very
transportable 3.2 pound magnesium alloy
body so it's built like a boss just like
the original it even has these new ports
so you'll find a usb 3.0 port a full
size media card reader on the other side
more usb 3.0 ports a full size hdmi port
and more and these neat slots on the
sides are actually high quality speakers
they're not events they're really nice
speakers so the only venting going on is
happening at the bottom back of this
laptop but i'm going to be totally
honest guys there is only one real
reason you buy this over the ux31 it's
not the massive specs it's not the six
hour battery life it's not even the
backlit keyboard which is cool um but
it's the display this 13-inch ultrabook
is rocking a 1920 by 1080p
ips display with a matte finish it's
awesome it's freaking beautiful very
color accurate very bright and the
trackpad is also nice and big so there's
plenty of room to move the mouse around
all these pixels has a nice high pixel
density and it responds well to some new
gestures thanks to some asus software so
that's a nice touch oh and it can do
this check it out
oh yeah i don't think your laptop can do
that but seriously this guy turns heads
it has the same finish on the back as
those high-end asus transformer pad
tablets very high quality it's an
all-around great machine basically
they've updated everything inside the
ux31 and crammed it into this nice sized
thin and light laptop in the ux32 and
it's not bad looking either it's a great
performer thanks to that ivy bridge
processor the ram the graphics card and
the ssd for cash a lot of people wonder
can you game on it yes you can you can
get away with some light to mid-range
gaming i wouldn't say crisis or anything
but it can handle minecraft easily world
of warcraft a little need for speed
stuff like that i happen to use this guy
for note taking in school so it goes
everywhere with me fits in my backpack
and i don't have to worry about it
bumping into things like textbooks with
that magnesium case so yeah it's a boss
it earns boss status congratulations
asus well done
so there you go guys this is a laptop i
can pretty much recommend for anyone it
is thin which makes it really light and
really really good for school i happen
to use this a lot for note-taking and a
lot for college or if you guys are
starting university it's a good thing to
check out so check out ultrabooks and
check out the ux32 the link to check it
out is down in the description below
either way thanks for watching this
review video this quick overview hope
you enjoy enjoyed and give it a thumbs
up if you did and i'll talk to you guys
in the very next video talk to you guys
later
you